[Music]
sleep actually enhances your memory and
it refreshes your learning ability you
need sleep after learning to essentially
hit the Save button on those new
memories so that you don't forget but
what we've also learned is that you need
sleep before learning as well and now -
almost prepare your brain a little bit
like a dry sponge ready to initially
soak up new information so you need
sleep on both sides of that equation and
that's why pulling the all-nighter
before the exam is a very bad idea when
you sleep you actually see almost a
three-fold increase in creative
abilities as a consequence and there's
some wonderful anecdotes demonstrating
this sleep inspired creative benefit
Keith Richards from the Rolling Stones
actually used to go to sleep with a
guitar and a tape recorder because he
understood the power of dream sleep what
we call REM sleep and he describes in
his autobiography how one night he
started the tape recorder
went to sleep and the next morning the
tape would run all the way through here
around it back and there in some ghostly
vision with the opening chords of
satisfaction the most famous Rolling
Stone song and then he said it was
followed by about 43 minutes of snoring
thereafter it's probably the reason that
no one has ever told you to stay awake
on a problem
sleep is a wonderful health panacea
every major disease that seems to be
killing us in the developed world has
significant and many of them causal
links to a lack of sleep so the two most
feared diseases which are Alzheimer's
disease and cancer both have strong
links to short sleep duration across the
lifespan short sleep will actually
predict all cause mortality so you may
have heard that old maxim people would
tell you that you can sleep when you're
dead
well it is mortally unwise advice if you
adopt that mindset we know from the
science that you will be both dead
sooner and the quality of that now
shorter life will be significantly worse
[Music]
less sleep does not equal more
productivity it's a fallacy that still
remains in business and it's actually a
very costly one too the RAND Corporation
several years ago performed a global
survey of the cost of sleep deprivation
across nations and what they found was
that insufficient sleep within the
workplace cost most nations about two
percent of their GDP so just think about
that if we could solve the sleep crisis
within the workplace we could perhaps
double the budget for education maybe we
could even half the healthcare deficit
that were suffering in most of these
developed nations so sound sleep is
sound business that's exactly what the
science teaches us
[Music]
you